[Music]
foreign
at you from a hotel room in Cupertino
California because today was Apple's
September event and this is your first
look your Hands-On and your impressions
and honest thoughts and everything you
need to know about the iPhone 14 lineup
and while the phones do look pretty
similar to last year there is a lot of
interesting stuff kind of tucked in and
I've got a lot of thoughts on it but as
you might know the September event it is
the iPhones and iPhone accessories and
so we did get new airpods and a new set
of watches including a new Apple watch
Ultra that I also got Hands-On time with
that'll be a separate video I'll link up
a little like button so you can check it
out when it's live or hopefully you're
already subscribed here with
notifications turned on in which case
you'll see it right away but that's
going to be a different video but for
now our new iPhones in 2022 we have the
iPhone 14 and 14 plus and then the
iPhone 14 pro and 14 pro Max rip to the
mini iPhone you had a good run so the
new Baseline iPhones as you can imagine
are pretty similar it's just one is much
bigger than the other one so the iPhone
14 and 14 Plus have 6.1 inch and 6.7
inch displays respectively my prediction
on waveform was that all the prices
would stay the same and that turned out
to be correct so the iPhone 14 is 7.99
and the bigger 14 plus is 8.99 and
really what you'll notice is these two
phones look very similar to last year
with some some bumps and refinements
here and there of course but they both
have the same a15 bionic chip as last
year the same design the same notch on
the outside I'm actually convinced that
a case that fits the iPhone 13 will fit
the iPhone 14 but the green is gone and
there is a new light blue that matches
my shirt extremely well but there's
three main things that are new here the
display the cameras and
connectivity if that makes sense so the
connectivity is the quirkiest one as you
can imagine uh you know how iPhones
forever have always had a little SIM
card tray on the side well in the US
starting with the iPhone 14 they will
not have SIM card trays anymore they
will be moving entirely to esim
electronic Sim which is fine I guess I
mean they work well it's typically very
easy to upgrade phones or even swap
between carriers but I have to wonder
naturally if this is also going to act
as a little bit of an extra wall in the
Walled Garden because now how hard is it
going to be to switch from an iPhone
to a non-iphone just something to think
about but anyway the iPhone 14's also
got satellite connectivity for SOS and
this is actually really impressive so in
areas where you don't have any Cellular
Connection but you still need to send a
message you will be able to talk to
satellites to still get a message sent
so now satellite connectivity is
notoriously pretty difficult you'd need
a big radio or at least something with
large external antennas and you need an
unobstructed view of the sky and you
have to point it directly at a satellite
I mean you've probably seen what a
starlink dish looks like so now Apple's
built this sensitivity into the iPhone
14s antennas and they've actually built
a piece of UI in where it'll actually
help you point directly at a satellite
and it will help you send that emergency
message it'll actually package it up
into a smaller format and within 30
seconds to one or two minutes it can
send a message even when you have no
cellular connectivity it's an edge case
hopefully you'll never have to use it
but that is pretty cool that it can get
it done
um and the details where it will be
coming to the US and Canada launching
later this year and it will be free for
two years and then that's all we kind of
know but as far as things you'll
actually use every day the displays are
the same size and resolutions as before
but they do get a bit brighter now 1200
nits Max for HDR content everything else
is the same and then there is a new
camera system a larger 12 megapixel main
sensor with sensor shift stabilization a
wider F 1.5 aperture for better photos
and hopefully better sensitivity and low
light and there is a new 12 megapixel
selfie camera on the front with
autofocus plus they've introduced this
whole new photonic engine again they
name everything but really that's just a
better image processing pipeline from
end to end which should improve across
the board low light sensitivity and
nighttime photos things like that
there's also a new action mode feature
in the camera that does much more
dramatic stabilization on super shaky
videos I definitely got to try this out
for myself it seems like it works best
with certain types of shots like the
ones they use in their demos but we'll
see basically the way I see it is these
new iPhone 14s and 14 pluses are
essentially an iPhone 13 Pro one year
later minus the telephoto camera and
minus the promotion OLED dressed in
aluminum like it's a very familiar phone
I guess on the plus side pun intended
having a larger iPhone with a 1080p 60hz
display means they can promise that this
will be the best battery life ever in an
iPhone this plus and I'm pretty sure
this plus is going to be a hit if I know
anything about regular people's phone
buying decisions I think spending an
extra 100 bucks for a way bigger screen
is a no-brainer so that's 7.99 for the
iPhone 14 and 8.99 for the 14 plus which
actually comes out a month later in
October for some reason but then we got
the iPhone 14 pro and 14 pro Max which
have a little bit more going on it's
still got all the new stuff from the 14
and 14 plus that I just talked about
satellite connectivity uh action mode in
the camera it's even the same two sizes
again 6.1 inches and 6.7 inches but
there are three new things here and
those are a new a16 bionic chip and an
even bigger camera upgrade and then this
thing called Dynamic Island
we'll get to it so the a16 bionic chip
inside is even more powerful and more
efficient as you can imagine it's now a
six core chip built on a four nanometer
process they're quoting forty percent
better than the competition sweet and
there's also actually a slight display
upgrade as well this is up to 2 000 nits
Max brightness Outdoors which is class
leading and the pro iPhones now finally
finally have an always-on display so you
can see still the time and if you have
notifications and even updated info on
your widgets while your phone is locked
and just sitting around on a table or
charging that I like a lot but the big
upgrades like I said are going to be the
camera and the cutout at the top okay so
the camera system is all new and it is
bigger like you can tell just by looking
at it that everything in here is bigger
it protrudes more off the back of the
phone but yeah technically speaking this
is the first time in about a decade that
we're actually getting a megapixel bump
this is a new 48 megapixel main camera
sensor on the 14 Pros so it's still
going to bend down to 12 megapixels for
normal shots you'll get 12 megapixel
images out of it but you'll hopefully be
able to reap the benefits of higher
detail better low light sensitivity from
a bigger sensor but also if you want to
shoot 48 megapixel photos you can you
just gotta shoot Pro raw then you'll get
48 megapixel shots and then they also
added a new 2x button into the camera UI
which might not seem like a big deal but
that turns out to just be an exact crop
using the middle 12 megapixels of the
sensor itself so you can hit that 2x
button to zoom in basically with Optical
quality which is much better than before
plus you still have the further 3x
telephoto lens the Sun is setting real
hardcore down here so sorry if I start
to look orange but I'm definitely
looking forward to test out these
cameras I've already been shooting a lot
with the iPhone 13 Pro on the new
autofocus Channel you might have seen
that if you've subscribe you've noticed
I've been experimenting with the cameras
over there but uh it'll be interesting
to see if we notice the difference by
starting to shoot those with an iPhone
14 pro and also comparing it to things
like the pixel and the s22 Ultras of the
world but then let's talk about this
Dynamic Island thing so okay I kid you
not when they first announced this that
they were going to name it a dynamic
Island literally the entire theater like
audibly laughed there was a laughter out
loud from the crowd
um and I thought it was hilarious like
why would they name the pill but then
they explained it
and The more I've used it and The more
I've actually played with it and
understood it since makes a lot of sense
and I actually really like it so
basically What's Happening Here is
Apple's shrunk down all the selfie
camera and the parts of the face ID
system down by about 30 and so they'll
fit in this pill-shaped cutout in the
top of the screen fine if they'd stopped
here that would be an incredibly minor
update I mean it's literally just
aesthetic not worth mentioning since we
see selfie cutouts all the time for
years now but then they went a step
further with it so since it's an OLED
and you can turn off any pixels to
appear pitch black they decided to play
with extending the edges of the pill
with more UI so if you have ongoing
notifications or live actions stuff like
music playing or timers in the
background or an Uber notification or
whatever those will show up and it has
this nice little animation to extend and
shrink and move around the cutout and it
works really really well so then you can
tap on the icon and to open that app and
take action or you can actually hold
down to surface extra information for
what's happening which basically just
looks like the widget that would be in
your notifications just without having
to pull down your notifications this is
cool it's pretty cool it works right
away with a bunch of the stock uh Apple
apps Apple Maps the timer the voicemails
and all that stuff but they say it will
also work with third-party apps now this
will be up to them how fast they want to
implement it fingers crossed that my
favorite apps like Spotify and things
like that get on it quickly we'll see
but yeah this immediately takes the the
whole pill cut out thing to a new level
the more I played around with it the
more I was impressed I was trying it
with multiple background activities
happening at the same time and basically
what happens is it would show both so
let's say if you have a timer and Maps
navigation and music playing all
happening in the background the dynamic
Island would low-key turn into like a
little multitasking UI and let you
quickly switch between these ongoing
things and it was already very intuitive
it also just seems to be pretty generous
about where you're tapping so obviously
if you tap exactly on just the camera
cutout itself well nothing will happen
because those aren't actual pixels it's
just the camera cutout but your finger
is big enough that it naturally hits
some of the pixels around the top and
the bottom of the cutout so it still
knows to respond pretty much anytime you
just tap the black bar and there's also
some active pixels in between you can
kind of see them at just the right angle
so if you touch in there it still
responds it's really good I think a lot
of people are gonna really love this you
remember back in the day when there was
like all these really friendly uh
wallpapers that would take advantage of
like a whole punch cut out that would go
viral because it's like oh that's a
really thoughtful way of hiding a hole
in the screen this is just like a a Next
Level upgrade moving version of that
it's it's really thoughtful playful
friendly and intuitive so it's just it's
just a level up version of that so even
if the cutout looks a little worse
sometimes when when playing full screen
videos or playing games I feel like it
kind of makes up for it by being so
useful so often also I hope this is the
last time I ever have to say the word
dynamic Island out loud it's stupid that
they had to name it but that's how apple
rolls so they named it but yeah that's
that's the new Pro phones also there's
this new purple color kind of a dull
lavender type of purple but again same
prices as last year too 9.99 and 10.99
starting and they go up to one terabyte
there's not a lot of crazy Innovative
Hardware design going on here nothing's
folding in half there's no super fast
high-end fast charging or wireless
charging it's just it's just a bunch of
little refinements again at this point
we know what the iPhone is Apple knows
what the iPhone is and they tend to be
late on the train to picking up on
things and then doing it in the apple
way that's pretty much exactly what's
happening with the cutout and that's
what the iPhone 14s are also they
sneakily left some of the 13s still in
the lineup the 13 Mini and the 13
Baseline are still available if you want
them 5.99 for the 13 mini and 6.99 for
the 13. now I don't have the new boxes
yet but I think it's pretty safe to
assume that none of the new boxes will
have Chargers in them because they
haven't for years now and that's where
the sponsor of this video comes in
Anchor you've heard of them so they've
got these two things that pair perfectly
with the new iPhones the new Anker Nano
3 and the new 541 cable so the nano3
charges with gallium nitride which
allows it to be way smaller this little
brick is a 30 watt charger which is good
for the iPhone or the iPad or the watch
or even the MacBook Air but it's
literally 70 smaller than Apple's 30
watt brick and the USBC to lightning
cable is the first I've seen to use
bio-based materials including sugar cane
and corn but it still feels exactly like
a good high quality cable because it is
one it's built to withstand 20 000 bends
there's a three or six foot version and
they both come in five colors including
this lilac purple you can check them out
at the a link below and pick up your own
but that's been it for this Hands-On and
the first look at the new lineup let me
know what you think of the new iPhones
honestly I think I think regular people
are gonna love the dynamic Island but
let me know what your thoughts are and I
also believe that the plus is going to
be a hit but I'll see in the comments
below what you guys are feeling and also
of course check out the other videos
when they come out link below when I
talk about the watch okay that's been it
thanks for watching catch you guys later
thank you
[Music]